et l'actualité de sam karmann c'est la
reprise le 3 avril au théâtre de marigny
du bonheur une comédie avec marie-anne
chazel voici la bande-annonce petit goal
eu chaud mais pas quand je lis ça va
prendre parti pourquoi se compliquer la
vie ce serait tellement plus simple et
didier vous ne plaisait on va baiser au
balcon
je suis dans le bonheur
actuellement le bonheur ce sera le 3
avril précisément voilà c'est presque
actuellement il va falloir encore
attendre un tout petit peu mise en scène
jean luc moreau vous interprétez
lesdites d'eric assous voile et vous
interpréter un quinquagénaire que la vie
a malmené vous rencontrez m'arrive de
chazelles là c'est de lui à seulement
n'ont pas morale ainsi leur seulement
amoureux et le message justement c'est
quoi alors c'est de montrer que quand on
a 50 ans on peut tomber amoureux c'est
vrai les difficultés de la vie bien sûr
moi les histoires d'amour elles n'ont
pas d'âge par contre c'est vrai que
c'est pas les mêmes histoires d'amour
quand on a
disons une vingtaine d'années où ce sont
c'est la première grande histoire
d'amour
on a tous en mémoire et puis il ya et
puis quand c'est une histoire où il ya
déjà eu plusieurs histoires et comment
on recommence une nouvelle histoire
d'amour parce que on a plus peut-être la
même disponibilité bon lui il est il est
pris dans son dans son travail et les
restaurants et travaille énormément il
ap
il ay là il est en instance de divorce
d'ailleurs il a il a trois filles
donc c'est un homme extrêmement occupés
qui travaille énormément où est la place
de la disponibilité de l'amour de la
rencontre amoureuse là dedans on en
parle un petit peu moins de l'amour à 50
ans justement s'insérer dans son
parlement
il faut que plus dans les films comme au
théâtre souvent de l'amour mais plus
quand on a 20 ans tant les comédies
romantiques c'est plutôt pour 30 ans oui
mais pas au baiia pas tant d'écart par
exemple et enfin bon
donc voilà ma et marianne elle sait que
c'est une c'est une femme qui est qui et
qui est libre qui est seul mais qui a
choisi d'être seul elle se trouve plus
plus épanouie dans cette situation et
puis voilà
la pièce commence c'est le fameux petit
déjeuner c'est ce fameux petits dés on
s'est rencontrés la veille
quand on connaît pas beaucoup l'autre
voilà on a passé la nuit le matin on se
lève et on présente une certaine image
de soi
compte tenu d envie de continuer ou pas
cette aventure d'une duel pourrait
suffire et puis elle elle décide que ça
suffit elle va l'enfermer elle va cacher
la clé elle va faire non tu vas pas
partir comme ça tu vas pas à venir
consommer et de barres et tu vas parler
un peu et à partir de là de cette prise
d'otages
comment les choses vont se dérouler
entre ce sera à découvrir ou à
redécouvrir parce que c'est une reprise
vous retourne wiesen vous n'aviez pas
fait le tour de cette pièce bien coûter
un succès au plaisir
on avait commencé le 31 août on est
infini le 23 janvier c'était prévu
d'abord pour finir au moins deux au
début décembre on a prolongé jusque fin
décembre puis jusqu'au 23 janvier
et puis voilà on avait des engagements
qui qui nous obligés d'arrêter
et puis le théâtre nous a demandé si on
était libres là pour faire 30 dates en
avril marianne était libre mais aussi
voilà on continue de votre succès oui
mais c'est aux victimes consentantes pas
ce que c'est on a énormément de plaisir
je cette pièce vous êtes un homme de
théâtre il ya donc le bonheur à re
découvrir à partir du 3 avril il ya eu
aussi cuisine et dépendances de jean
pierre bacri et agnès jaoui il ya aussi
des classiques au début de votre
carrière crime et châtiment domjan quel
est votre plus beau souvenir c'est sa
saison dont césar de bazan c'est un
personnage dans ruy blas que j'ai joué
j'ai joué rue blaes plusieurs fois avec
des petits rôles dans une compagnie
parce que pendant les dix premières
années de ma vie j'ai fait un travail de
compagnie avec la compagnie
renaud-barrault avec la prime et surtout
avec la compagnie jean pierre bouvier et
j'ai eu la chance de jouer les grands
textes avec lui et quand j'ai intégré la
compagnie c'était un tout petit rôle je
tenais un flambeau dans ruy blas et puis
on l'a repris d'année en année et on a
fait une reprise
huit ans plus tard où je jouais dans
césar de bazan voilà il ya des rôles
comme ça qui vous forme
je crois que les grands rôles font les
grandes performances si mal que ça roule
d'une porte chance une façon générale il
m'a appelé m'a porté chance sur le homme
de théâtre et de cinéma alors le grand
public qui vous connaît pour cuisines et
dépendances qui était une adaptation de
la pièce de théâtre il ya aussi la cité
de la peur devenu un film culte pour
toute une génération
je vous avoue que j'en fais partie j'en
suis désolé on va avoir le plaisir
peut-être pour mon plaisir un petit
extrait je veux dire quelque chose odile
on ne peut pas tromper une personne
mille fois c'est ce plan sinon on peut
tromper mille personnes l'une mille fois
non
on compte on peut tromper une fois mille
personnes odile mais on ne peut pas
tromper une fois mille personnes
oui non on ne peut pas tromper mille
fois ok ce rôle des milles ça fait seize
ce film ça fait vingt ans ça fera 20 ans
l'an prochain que la saison bientôt les
petits enfants l'intergénérationnel ça
vous agace pas un petit peu non banon a
mérité aux graves c'est formidable
d'avoir des films cultes comme ça et
puis voilà et voilà sa fille de mike
hulme et cuisine aussi cuisine et
dépendances ça a été une pièce comme ça
culte à son époque le film la fel a fait
durer c'est formidable d'avoir comme ça
des points de repère dans une carrière
je passe mon âme en fin de saison dans
une vie d'acteur
vous n'avez pas peur vous n'avez pas eu
peur comme tous les acteurs je le dis
souvent d'être aussi enfermé catalogué
parce qu'en france on aime bien ça
enfermer les acteurs dans certains rôles
après j'ai cité de la peur après cuisine
et dépendances c'est à dire que moi mais
mon rôle je les ai eus plus à la
télévision qu'au cinéma mais au cinéma
j'ai bon voilà il ya des films aussi
déjanté que la cité de la peur ou dont
on a peu parlé mais qui sont cultes qui
s'appelle les dents de la nuit c'est une
espèce de folie mais j'ai fait aussi à
la télévision par exemple le rêve
d'esther un rôle extrêmement dramatique
voilà je jeune homme et puis j'ai
réalisé aussi des films et donc ça m'a
permis ses différentes casquettes
réacteurs acteurs théâtre cinéma
télévision
ça me permet justement de ébats de
d'être une anguille et de me faufiler
entre de me filer justement entre les
les pancartes comportent chacun quoi on
profite de votre présence pour dérouler
un petit peu un set cette riche carrière
au début en tant qu'acteur le grand
pardon avec son arcady 1982 histoire de
claude de famille tenue par roger hanin
des souvenirs de cette époque aussi
passé le début se bat le
le voilà bah là c'était le grand pardon
le mon premier plan de cinéma j'étais
dans les toilettes et on me demandait de
baisser mon pantalon une tombe est mort
parce que bacri venait me tuer et je
montrais mes fesses je me suis mis à
dessiner mans quoi c'est ça il faut
montrer faut montrer sont originaires de
vaulx premier plan de cinéma et on en
parle aussi peut-être moins mais vous
avez décroché un oscar si oui oui un
court métrage court métrage omnibus
c'était en 93 alors des horaires de la
sncf qui changent la vie qui est
bouleversée pour un homme c'est huit
minutes à la clé donc cet oscar palme
d'or césar n'ont pas saisis pas le césar
vous n'est pas le cerveau été nommé en
tout cas pour le césar mais il y avait
eu effectivement l'oscar le carrière
l'américaine ça vous aurait pas tenté on
parle souvent de jean dujardin qui il a
eu sept oscars ni alors je vais vous
dire justement alors la carrière de
l'américaine comme un acteur peut-être
mais comme un réalisateur il me sens moi
ce qui m'intéresse dans le cinéma c'est
de mettre ces de diriger les acteurs et
je pense que la langue même si je crois
parler assez bien l'anglais je ne la
parle parce que j'ai joué en anglais
avec des acteurs américains et je me
suis rendu compte que j'étais à 80 % de
mes moyens eux ils étaient 150 et on est
il ya quelque chose dans la langue qui
fait que je vois là je me suis dit non
je vais pas aller faire des films aux
états unis même si on me l'a proposé à
l'époque
et quand vous avez décroché l'oscar vous
avez pensé quoi ce moment là ça y est
l'amérique s'ouvre à moi qui se comprend
ça sans moi
on pense que c'est incroyable que ça
n'existe pas on pense qu'on pense qu'on
s'est trompé c'est une énorme arnaque et
qu'on va se réveiller le lendemain qu'on
va vous dire d'un an c'était des
conneries non la statuette est toujours
là cet oscar arias dont qu'il ait eu ces
réalisations mais en france vous nous
l'avez dit vous préférez réalisé en
français kennedy et moi la petite
semaine la vérité ou presque également
peut-être plus rares à la réalisation
pourquoi vous fait ses choix c'est très
espacées ses traits à ce que j'ai
vraiment à 100 je joue entre temps parce
que je ne suis pas que réalisateur parce
que je ne sais pas ce que je ne fais pas
que hauteur parce que parce que jouer
pour moi c'est du plaisir et mettre en
scène c'est du travail et que j'alterne
travail et plaisir
on va les images de kennedy et mois
prochain film où jean sarrailh et oui
j'ai voilà jeu pour l'instant je
travaille sur des pistes on ne sait pas
encore si ces pistes ont même des câbles
ou pas en tout cas vous êtes très engagé
on a pu le comprendre depuis le début de
cette émission vous avez signé notamment
aussi une réponse à vincent maraval
c'était l'agent qui dénonçaient ces
acteurs trop payés vous l'avez
apprécié cette sortie dans la presse les
acteurs ne sont pas des noms si c'était
votre réponse mais vraiment est encore
en travers de la gorge parce que maraval
sur bien des points j'étais d'accord
avec lui donc simplement
alors j'en profite pour dire que cette
chose là je les mises sur facebook et
que c'est et repris laisser le mag qui a
été chercher ce monsieur bah oui c'est
vrai que facebook
j'ai pris conscience que c'était public
en fait je les faits pour lesquels que
le personnes qui étaient sur ma page
facebook et je me suis aperçu que c'est
devenu un
voilà ça en deux jours il y avait trois
mille 500 connexions incroyable et pour
revenir mais c'est pas moi qui l'a
envoyé aux médias c'est ça que je
voulais dire et pour cette réponse dans
le fond alors dans ce que vous avez pu
apporter comme répondent à des phrases
des acteurs voilà les nantis mais non
bien sûr que non il ya pour pour 15 15
ou 20 stars qui sont millionnaires c'est
vrai tant mieux pour elle mais il ya
trente mille acteurs qui est jeu voilà
il ya des acteurs du conservatoire qui
était avec moi il ya trente ans qu'ils
sont et rémy franchement donc ou rsa
maintenant ça s'appellera ça donc c'est
pas vrai c'est très courageux de vouloir
être acteur leleu
il ya très peu d'élus très peu d'élus
qui vivent correctement il ya très peu
moi je suis un cadre moyen supérieur du
métier je vois la même pour être un
cadre moyen supérieur du métier je vous
assure on est très peu ont derrière nous
il ya énormément d'acteurs qui galère il
ya des idées il faut être extrêmement
passionnées moi je passe mon temps à
dire aux jeunes s'il ya la moindre chose
qui put qui puisse vous intéresser à
part ça fait le c'est très dur d'être
acteur voilà vous êtes très engagé mais
très discret aussi on voit finalement
assez peu vous aimez aussi avoir votre
jardin secret pas vous exposer on ne
voit pas dans chaque chaque magazine
people on va dire comme beaucoup de
stars on va tout de même essayer d'en
savoir un peu plus sur vous à travers un
questionnaire année de naissance il est
né en 1953
je serai une actrice vous ne diriez pas
c'est vrai je me suis désolé mais
aujourd'hui on est sur la parité donc
les revoilà nous sommes donc né en 1953
je vous donner une liste de
personnalités elles aussi sont nés la
même année vous allez me dire si oui ou
non vous vous sentez proche d'elle ou
aussi et si pourquoi voilà pourquoi pas
un philippe douste-blazy hommes
politiques ump 1953 aussi très bien pour
lui et non plus pauvres du sein d'une
ump gentilly josé bové figure du
mouvement altermondialiste il fait plus
vieux points dont 53 bah oui bien sûr
ségolène royal c'est vrai qu'elle est de
53 très jolies femmes alors vous sentez
plutôt proche justement d'elle de ses
idées par rapport à philippe
douste-blazy
oui je me souviens de la date d'avoir
été l'écouté d'ailleurs quand elle était
en campagne présidentielle parce que
c'est un secret pour personne que je
suis quand même de gauche donc voilà je
le dis oui patrick sébastien morissette
53 alors patrick sébastien je crois que
je les jeux les croiser une fois quand
il était dans un petit bar où c'est plus
sûr non moi je faisais là je faisais la
plongée lui passait je vous parle de ça
en 1978 au port du salut alors vous sent
tellement d'idées mme harel lui ni débat
ni démarrer qu'est ce que vous pensez
que le jeu qu'on se résume toujours rien
pas isabelle huppert une personnalité
d'ailleurs je vous parle comédienne je
ne connais pas personnellement mais
j'aime beaucoup cette actrice et john
malkovich comédien américain 53 bien sûr
formidable il a mis en scène la
dernièrement la cette pièce
bon voila j'ai pu le titre merci je suis
pas venu vous aider en plus donc c'est
pas forcément réalisable
on m'a même pas dit non dans
l'oreillette on va aller rechercher pour
bolt et a même dit qu'on ne sait pas
bravo il vous reste encore quelques
instants pour aller chercher sans régime
quiz
on les voit qui est tout à leur
brièvement votre engagement politique
vous nous l'avez dit vous êtes de gauche
mais ça s'est passé pas une surprise
c'est pas un secret françois hollande
qui est à 30 % dans les sondages
bah ouais bah ouais les soirs vous êtes
déçu de sa politique vous faites partie
des déçus c'est difficile de dire ça
parce que c'est tellement facile de dire
qu'on est déçu alors la fois jeu
je suis très embêté je suis très heureux
je pense je pensais franchement que je
pensais franchement qu'on était qu'on
serait moins dépendant de l'allemagne
pas franchement je veux dire je veux pas
tirer trop non plus c'est très complexe
mais j'ai envie de dire quand même il ya
des gens comme les économistes atterrés
qui nous explique que ça pourrait être
autrement si on avait un peu plus de
courage et je pense que si on veut une
europe
je suis profondément européen mais cran
quand je vois ce qui se passe
conséquences pour je vois ce que
l'europe impose la sans arrêt protège la
finance et est toujours dans le même
sens c'est fatigant ouais c'est fatigant
je suis un homme de gauche fatigue
peut-être une photo qui va vous remonter
le moral une toute dernière photo pour
terminer cette interview cette séquence
et vous me dites ce que vous voulez que
vous inspire cette photo il faut voit
sourire jusqu'aux deux garçons oui vous
l'avez déjà vu quelque part oui j'ai dit
aux gars que par son prénom
les oléo son nom de famille carmon
karman me semble bien ou alors lui aussi
veut se lancer cinéma réalisateurs court
métrage il en a déjà signé un vous
l'encouragez ont voulu dit ouais je sais
pas dans cette voie
vous savez j'en ai deux j'en ai un qui
s'appelle les hauts de l'aude s'est
sauvé de martin vives et dont il va être
réalisateur j'en suis sûr l'eau doit
être acteur j'en suis sûr et j'ai passé
j'ai passé mon temps à leur dire surtout
fait autre chose je ne fête pas comme
papa juste avant de les embrasser le
soin en dix ans et maintenant je vais
jouer alors c'est difficile quoi c'est
difficile de rester crédible dans ces
cas là merci sam karmann je sais que
vous devez partir sur paris on vous
regarde juste encore quelques instants
nous avons parlé à cinéma théâtre dans
la suite du 7-8
j'aimerais encore vous entendre un petit
peu